Everest conquered on May 29th 1953
Edmund Hillary and Sherpa Tenzing Norgay
made history as the first climbers to
reach the summit of Mount Everest the
world's tallest mountain two unassuming
man had climbed the 29,000 foot monarch
of the Himalayas in England present-day
runner John Griffin has had plenty of
free time during his country's lockdown
and his three-story home has plenty of
stairs which planted a thought in his
head my idea the other day and I just
walked to the top of my house to my
bedroom for the fifth time and I said to
my wife I think by the time this crisis
is over I will have climbed Everest
inspired the 53 year old decided to do
it climb the equivalent of the height of
Mount Everest an amazing 29,035 feet one
step at a time not just for the
challenge and the exercise but also to
raise money for UK food banks earlier
this week he began his ascent with the
help of a computer program to track his
progress at the halfway point he
celebrated in typical British fashion
finally four days 29 hours and 41
thousand steps later
Griffin reached the summit of his own
imaginary Mountain greeted by his family
on a rooftop terrace a worthy substitute
for what climbers call the roof of the
world so getting exercise getting people
who need its food and putting smiles on
people's faces not bad Dana I'm glad he
did it and not me that's all I'll say